Captain Malcolm Reynolds to return to
the serenity
that that's too good to be true is it
even remotely possible though welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
so a couple of times over the last year
or so I've been able to tell you that
Disney would absolutely love to bring
back some sort of version of the
firefight series now the main reason why
they'd like to bring the series back is
because it regularly tops lists of the
all-time favorite sci-fi shows ever
and it was popular enough that it did
spawn its own movie that was also
reasonably popular even though this
Series has not been in our screens for
nearly two decades the brown coats are
still as excitable and is interested in
the Firefly show as they ever were
but also and most importantly since
Disney put the Firefly on their Disney
Plus network it's got really really good
views people re-watch it over and over
again I know this for a fact because I
I'm one of those people
I think I'm on my third time at the
moment since Firefly appeared on Disney
Plus
I quite like this show
but as I also reported to you probably
got away in nine months now Disney
didn't quite know what to do with
firefly they knew that this was such a
popular series that if they got it wrong
with some sort of hard reboot or
something that well it would be
massively unpopular very very quickly in
fact they're reasonably sure that it
would be unpopular before it ever even
appeared on screens I mean look at what
happened to the rings of power for
Amazon
opinion hate clickers people that just
do videos on YouTube to talk crap they
would tear this series apart if they
tried to do a reboot without some or
most of the main actors to return
so Disney did set up loads of meetings
with different producers different
consultant things to discuss what would
be the best thing to do with this show
we want to bring it back
how do we do that without turning
everybody against us
they even talk to people like John
Favreau and even he couldn't come up
with a decent solution apparently
there's even been some quite quiet
conversations with Joss Whedon now Josh
Whedon is a little bit of a problem
there are some quite negative things
going around about him some quite
negative stories Charisma Carpenter's
allegations towards him are not pleasant
he has become a little bit of a
difficult character to work with over
the years because I remember you told me
in the first interview that there was a
time where he kind of put you against
the wall and said something to you and
that was like you know I said
he was joking and you go no no so maybe
just he actually said look Joss isn't a
bad guy he's not a difficult person to
work with but he is a perfectionist now
even though he then went on to admit
that actually Josh had him up against a
wall at one point and was screaming at
him which is a little bit aggressive it
does seem that Josh reading is just
somebody that actually is a
perfectionist and just want things his
way I was basically ruining his show
basically forcing him to keep you on
because you're doing so well yes but the
thing is is that that is going to change
the show from being about a teenager
overcoming
adolescence and when he doesn't get it
he gets pissed off and at times that
comes across as a bullying I've actually
Heard lots of interviews with Nathan
feeling them and he says he never saw
that actually the people that worked on
firefight loved working together they
still have a Serenity Valley WhatsApp
group apparently and they still talk to
each other regularly but my question is
and you could just divert if you want
what if they do these projects without
Joss Whedon
oh that would be heartbreak
because he created them yeah those are
those are his
how can you Nathan Fillion and Alan
tudik have gone on to become really best
friends just Google them now and search
all the videos and things they've done
together over the years okay uh you know
what it sounds like Beckett left he's uh
he's probably gonna meet me here but he
wouldn't go out without me
yeah no problem yeah just when he gets
here just let me know
great and you can introduce me anytime
everybody
all right everybody
please welcome Nathan fillingham
I know
this was a happy family and Joe Sweden
was a big part of that but when Disney
Then spoke to these people including
John Favreau as I said none of them
could come up with a reasonable answer
to the question how do we bring Firefly
back without turning the fans against us
the only thing that they could agree on
was if you can get Nathan Fillion
involved the fans will go freaking crazy
now that wasn't really a possibility but
Disney did apparently according to my
sources that I speak to put out a hand
they asked the question to Nathan if we
were to do a Revival of the Firefly and
we got an interesting story would you be
interested
and to their surprise
he answered yes talking about reboost
would you would you do you've been asked
a million times but would you do that
why wouldn't I do that it was one of the
best things that ever happened to me now
this is maybe going to be years off
something he does after the rookie well
no because according to my source again
it was actually spoken directly with
Nathan Fillion
he says that Nathan would be very keen
to return so Keen in fact that he might
even walk away from the rookie now why
would he do that there's a couple of
reasons
you can go on any interview ever and
look at Nathan Fillion talking about the
Firefly it's the one show that he adored
he's been asked before now would you be
interested in buying the franchise and
he actually said look if I won the
California Lottery tomorrow and I won
like hundreds of millions of dollars I
would buy Firefly and I would remake it
that is how much he loved this project
and how keenly would be to bring it back
but would he really walk away from the
rookie well another thing that Nathan
Fillion is talked about in loads and
loads of interviews and did actually
discuss with my source was that the
22-24 whatever episodes a year is
incredibly exhausting now Nathan Fillion
is the kind of guy he's very relaxed
he's very chilled he loves working but
he also loves having fun spending time
going boating this sort of thing he has
his Hobbies Etc now he actually talked
to my source about how when he was doing
the castle series you could see by the
end of it he was exhausted and tired it
was a series that focused really just on
the two characters which basically means
for eight nine months of the year he was
having 16 hour days now he says that has
been a little bit easier on the rocky
because it's a bigger cast the whole
series doesn't surround only around him
there's eight or nine really strong
characters in there so he's not
appearing in every single scene like he
did in Castle
but doing 22 Episodes a year is still
exhausting and he says the other thing
is it stops him from doing other things
that come along
there are movie Parts etc etc he keeps
having to turn down because he just
doesn't have the time by the time he's
done the rookie which as I say takes up
eight nine months of the year he really
has a couple of months to rest and
recuperate and he's already thinking
about the next season
now the rookie has just had five
successful Seasons he is thinking that
maybe that'll do and actually he
wouldn't mind walking away or at very
least
stepping back even further to allow him
to one do other projects but for two
maybe have a serious conversation with
Disney about bringing back Firefly but
how would you bring back such an amazing
series how would you do it that's such a
big gap obviously Malcolm Reynolds is
now a fair bit older well apparently
that conversation has already been had
and Nathan Fillion is the one that came
up with the idea he said look you do a
really simple plot Captain Reynolds is
on his own he's lost the rest of the
crew after everything that happened in
the movie Serenity he broke down and
then over a mini series at very least we
would see him reconnect with some of
those characters and we would see him
refine himself he says it would be
really interesting to see what would
have actually happened to Captain
Reynolds following everything that
happened in the movie and then such loss
losing wash for example how would he
have reacted to that and would it have
broken him
so when we actually see Malcolm Reynolds
at the start of this proposed possible
new series we would see a broken Captain
Reynolds and then over that season maybe
two
we would get to seeing him refine
himself and maybe resolve some of those
demons that we know he's carrying
following the Civil War and maybe we
would get to see that Journey towards
the healing that was always planned for
the Firefly series
I'd also love to see what happened to
some of the other characters I want to
see where Wash's kid is washer's kid
should be now another pilot that that
should be done I want to see where
everybody else I want to see where Jane
is I want to see all of these characters
return
obviously there's the whole thing about
River and what happened there
that would also be really interesting to
see and she is an awesome actress who
I'd love to see return
the only shame will be we won't get to
see Alan Tudyk
but it's sci-fi
you live in a spaceship dear we've got a
scene return for at least one episode
you could do like an act of gas episode
where you know he's injured and you know
wash is just there keeps talking to him
but you know it's a ghost it's really in
his head even if they just did that
attitude it must return but guys get
into the comments to tell me what you
think if the Firefly was to return
would you be okay with it as long as
Nathan Fillion was still Captain Malcolm
Reynolds
or actually it's not just a show that
should never return we've got our
episodes we've got that little series we
go back to it all the time
we don't need more or do you agree with
me that I think the Philly wants to do
it who's just saying no
I would love to know exactly what you're
thinking if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go over to the sides
Channel where I do weekly Stargate
videos that if you're a gator you don't
want to miss you can also go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where you can get most of our new videos
from both channels first and for a small
contribution each month you get to see
them without the adverts before
everybody else on YouTube
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
you can also go to patreon.com
foreign
[Music]